[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
for e
it's
[Music]
e
sh
[Music]
couple things
I think was like two or three times you
got stuck on the gave you
a and then you lost I'm not talking
about that when you went here and his
back there not necessarily talking about
that I talk you about I can tell your
mindu here
the
so sometimes this
happens but as soon as you touch the
can't actually take your mind off the we
and start finding other a lot of times
you are say you're coming this way and
you you're like looking like that I'm
I'm not necessarily necessarily saying
to do that I'm just saying get your mind
out there
okay uh another one was let's say I
threw you this way okay and he's not
quite here no coming at me you see and I
got a separation here just engagement
but as as I'm waiting here for him and
you're not coming in there couple times
like two times I think you weren't
coming in and now you're coming at me
and then you come at me right you see
that so you can let's say same thing go
this way okay I throw you
and you're not quite coming at me I can
go to you do you see and then he'll
he'll come at you okay but I got to keep
moving from you cuz now I'm going to get
trapped does that make sense okay and
then another thing is when you're
looking for
time uh don't let the guy musy mus
couple times you wouldn't even roll you
know what I'm talking about you like
like went down on the and you went
around your leg Yeah you see
that if if you're looking for time
that's a much
quicker do
do yes you see he's right there now or
he should have been out there you know
what I mean so you have to make sure
that that see how I kep pulling that as
as he kept lowering you see
that he's he starts to lower on you he's
going under you what he's doing so you
keep pulling this one around the
adhesion to get more Cal energy does
that make sense oh you're here just
starting to go under me
here okay you feel that
counter uh look for that okay all right
[Music]
okay so like two times you tried that
move and then the Third time it got you
okay so let me
uh okay so you t count the wrong way so
Happ you t count it's going to give you
a back so you going like
this so you have a couple options you
can take this one
further I did that to you guys a lot
okay another one is you don't have to
throw him you can just pass him so that
you're not in the middle okay I know I
gave you you do coach you net but I just
don't want to see other
throws right there's ones where I didn't
throw I just went to the next one okay
so you you can do that one so instead of
coming here and you give your back to
this person and then you hold that
enough to do that
no don't put yourself in the
middle okay you either come all the way
around now you have a obstacle there
this is not the middle you can see it's
going the other way so you're confusing
the 10 call on when to do it and
then you're coming in right I pass him
and I him and now I don't I don't have
my back to any okay
try that's
better
good
good oh you're waiting for
him that's it go you're still in there
[Music]
there's the tank good okay
all right I don't know if it's going to
come up but let's see if it comes up but
as guys keep talking just keep going
okay you got it okay we go
[Music]
so there's no reason
why have
to stick with you need
so for
example coming in I don't want to go
here and even get in that
problem so as you're coming in I'm
moving
right this fting I'm moving right every
time you get your B so same thing you
get your V
and I'm
moving the situation Chang now you see
that so in
between the obvious I go
here get it that looks
like
is see that movement there right
okay don't get trapped in your ke you
know
a
okay okay so as as you're moving to get
a better situation than this you see is
you're trying to stack them so you have
a unified front and Not Your Flank so
right here
I'm flank even if I were to get out of
it I move into being flanked on both
sides
okay and what I'm doing
instead is I'm trying to stack you so
you would be coming in right and I'm
trying stack you see okay so I'm trying
to stack
you and then I'm trying to take you into
the spiral geometry you see that so
we're doing the same move
you had to turn you see that so we come
back we go a little
slower I'm coming over here I stack your
turn there's the counter rotation now
you see that just like in the video you
were doing do it again so you can see
what I'm talking about so for example
here right I'm going this way tries to
box me off and that's where I counter
rotate Okay so the same thing
here and we're going around okay there's
the stack you see and you already trying
to box me off if you pay attention
because stay where you are don't move
move him out of the way and you go
straight you're not on me now you're on
where you think I'm going to go that's
to try to box me in you know once you
try to box me in that's where the
counter rotation Works
evener get it as supposed
to over here and here you are stop which
you're right here just coming out you
and so there will be less than tripal
energy and I'll be moving back into that
line so again we go here and I go to
throw him here you are and you hear
where I am again double
F Okay so when you when you're moving
free throw you're trying
to
unify their field and then take it into
the spiral rotation okay that's what
you're trying to do all
right watch the double
flanking double flanking whoa
double
[Music]
flank hey